welcome back to CBS this morning if
you're just joining us we've been
covering the Dallas sniper shootings all
morning long five police officers have
been killed in an ambush during peaceful
demonstrations last night seven other
officers and two civilians were wounded
the city's mayor tells CBS this morning
three suspects are in custody and a
fourth suspect is dead we are now
awaiting a news conference in Dallas
with the city's mayor and police chief
we will bring that to you live as it
happens in a special report as we wait
for that former chief Washington
correspondent Face the Nation moderator
Bob Schieffer is from Texas grew up
there he started as a reporter there
more than half a century ago bob is now
a CBS News contributor he is in
Washington Bob it is it is good to see
you I know we're still waiting for a lot
of information here Bob as you know
we'll go to this report when it happens
but what do you make of what what you've
seen so far well I think what the mayor
is going to say in this news conference
is going to be very very important
because what's happened here
Jeff is different than any of these
recent violent events that we we have
been talking about this was not a random
act by some deranged person this was a
carefully planned military-style
operation this was a classic ambush
where the ambushers put their shooters
on the high ground surrounded a certain
place and then let their prey walk into
their line of fire they were also very
good shots these were people that knew
how to use these weapons we know that by
the by the accuracy by the number of
police officers that were shot they were
obviously shooting that police they were
not shooting at the protesters and they
were successful obviously 12 people were
shot five police officers are dead the
question now is who are these people is
this some kind of organized group could
it be terrorists the Dallas mayor has
said already this morning that he is not
ruling out anything as to what the
motive
or how these who these people are so as
we begin to identify these shooters
we'll have a better idea of what their
motivation was this may be tied to some
of the police shootings we have been
seen around the country it may be
something entirely different those are
the things that we hope to find out more
about when the Dallas officials hold
this news conference
we've been going on hours now still
don't have a ton of information Bob but
I want to ask you because I think you
provide such great perspective covering
so many events over the last 60 years
the civil rights movement JFK's
assassination Vietnam can you put into
context the type of divisive this we're
seeing in this country and the rhetoric
we're seeing well I think one thing that
we overlooked Jamie is our culture is
changing I don't think there's any
question about that we are becoming a
less patient society we are becoming a
more demanding society for one of a
better word we're becoming a ruder
Society and we see this playing out in
road rage in the way we treat one
another there's just almost people
nobody is satisfied with anything now
people are dissatisfied they're
frustrated and and they act out on these
things and when you put those who are
deranged
into the mix and they have access to
these very powerful weapons of war it
just makes the stakes even higher
there's no excuse for the some of the
police shootings that we we have been
seeing police are shooting first and
asking questions later but on the other
hand you have to remember that the
police are scared too of these weapons
that is why they are on such a
hair-trigger now it's going to take
great training and we're going to have
to have more of it for our police
departments around the country the
ironic thing and I think Scott Pelley
talked about this earlier the Dallas
Police Department is a very good Police
Department they've been very transparent
they put emphasis on come
unity policing the mayor Mike Rollins I
know him personally
he's a very upstanding guy he is very
forward-thinking
he enjoys very bipartisan support from
both Republicans and Democrats in Dallas
it is somewhat ironic that this would
happen in of all places Dallas where
their police department has done such a
good job but again I go back to this we
do not yet know what the motivation of
these shooters is this may be something
totally unrelated probably not but it
could be something totally unrelated
unrelated to some of these police
shootings that we've been seeing across
the country this might be the work of
terrorists we're gonna find out
eventually but right now we simply don't
know until we do find out Bob the fact
is is that the anger in this country
really does seem to be at a tipping
point and that it is a very very scary
feeling I'm sure for a lot of people
that woke up this morning to this news
thanks to we all experienced what
lawmakers need to do to finally turn
this corner well nobody knows the answer
to this because there are so many things
that this is so complex but you're
exactly right we wake up each morning
wondering what could happen today that
is worse than what happened yesterday
I'm now told that we're going now the
mayor is coming out we're going now to
that special report let's go directly
there